TUCKER THESE DAYS, IN MOSCOW.
ALL RIGHT.
NIC ROBERTSON, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT EYE-OPENING
REPORT.
APPRECIATE IT.
JOINED BY LEGENDARY CHESS GRAND
MASTER AND OUTSPOKEN PUTIN
CRITIC GARRY KASPAROV AND
CHAIRMAN OF THE HUMAN RIGHTS
NEGOTIATION AND HUMAN RIGHTS
INITIATIVE.
GARY, YOU RECENTLY MADE THE
POINT VLADIMIR PUTIN IS NOT
PLAYING CHESS, PLAYING POKER,
AND YOU THINK HE IS BLUFFING.
WHAT TO YOU MAKE OF WHAT WE JUST
SAW IN NIC ROBERTSON REPORT HOW
THEY ARE, YOU KNOW, MANIPULATING
THEIR AUDIENCES INTO THINKING
THAT BECAUSE TUCKER CARLSON IS
SPOUTING THESE TALKING POINTS
THERE IS A DECENT LEVEL OF
SUPPORT IN THE UNITED STATES FOR
WHAT VLADIMIR PUTIN IS UP TO
RIGHT NOW?
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS HIS OVERALL
END GAME?
>> TUCKER CARLSON --
>> BOTH.
>> TUCKER CARLSON HAS BECOME A
MOUTH PIECE OF RUSSIAN
PROPAGANDA.
YES.
HE'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
THAT'S THE GIFT FROM HEAVEN FOR
PUTIN'S PROPAGANDA MACHINE.
NOW THEY CAN QUOTE AS A
LEGITIMATE, HOST OF BIG TALK
SHOW WHO CAN ADDRESS NEARLY HALF
OF AMERICAN HOUSEHOLDS, AND HIS
VIEWS ARE YOU KNOW, TO SAY
RUSSIA IS NOT CORRECT BECAUSE
IT'S FOR PUTIN.
RUSSIA HAS NO INTEREST OF
FIGHTING THIS WAR AGAINST
UKRAINE NO INTEREST SUBDUING
NEIGHBORING NATIONS AND
CONTINUING THIS AGGRESSIVE
VLADIMIR PUTIN POLICIES.
SO IN THE PAST WE KNEW PEOPLE
LIKE TUCKER CARLSON WERE EITHER
WORKING DIRECTLY OR SOME
INTEREST FOR COMMUNIST REGIME
AND KGB OR EDICTS, NOW TUCKER
PARSEN A TRUMPIST AND FOR SOME
REASON NEVER CRITICIZED VLADIMIR
PUTIN AND QUITE NATURAL FOR
TUCKER CARLSON TO CONTINUE THIS
CAMPAIGN EXHILARATING PUTIN FROM
WHAT HE HAS BEEN DOING.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS A FASCIST
DICTATOR WHO HAS BEEN CONSISTENT
IN HIS CAMPAIGN TO DESTROY
RUSSIAN POSITION AT HOME.
ALL PEOPLE WHO MARCH FOR PEACE
IN RUSSIA EVENINGER IN JAIL,
KILLED OR IN EXILE LIKE MYSELF.
ALSO, PUTIN LAUNCHED CAMPAIGNS.
MILITARY CAMPAIGNS, AGAINST ANY
COUNTRY IN NEARBY THAT WANTED TO
ESCAPE FROM HIS, WHAT HE
CALLS -- HE WAS VERY CONSISTENT.
SINCE 2007 WHEN HE MADE HIS
SPEECH IN MUNICH AT SECURITY
CONFERENCE IN EUROPE.
SO HE, HE NEVER RETREATED FROM
HIS IDEA THAT RUSSIA WAS, WAS IN
A POSITION TO CONTROL NOT ONLY
FORMER SOVIET REPUBLICAN, ALSO
EASTERN EUROPE NATIONS AND WE
KNOW PUTIN NEVER LIMITED
AMBITIONS IN THIS PART OF THE
WORLD.
INSTRUMENTAL IN OUT AL ASSAD IN
SYRIA AND NEVER --
>> GARY, DO YOU THINK THAT IS
WHY THE U.S. IS TAKING VLADIMIR
PUTIN SO SERIOUSLY TO SOME
EXTENT?
BECAUSE IF THEY WERE JUST TO
COME OUT AND DO WHAT YOU'RE
DOING RIGHT NOW AND CALL PUTIN'S
BLUFF, WOULDN'T PUTIN WERE
TEMPTED TO PUFF OUT HIS CHEST
AND SAY, NO, I AM SERIOUS AND
THEN DO SOMETHING?
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT HOW VERY
DELICATE THAT PROPOSITION IS FOR
THE U.S. ADMINISTRATION?
>> YEAH.
IT IS DELICATE.
LET'S NOT FORGET, DELVE INTO
PUTIN'S PROBLEM AND OM NOW
SHOWING SERIOUSNESS, BECAUSE
SIMPLY INCREASING DEGREE IN
THREATS, IT DOESN'T CHANGE
PUTIN'S CALCULATIONS.
IF HE DOESN'T BELIEVE.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET.
PUTIN HAS -- HE NEVER ASKS WHY.
IT'S ALWAYS, WHY NOT?
WHAT CAN STOP PUTIN FROM
ATTACKING UKRAINE OR DOING OTHER
THINGS IS PROHIBITIVE COSTS AND
ONLY ACTIONS WILL CHANGE PUTIN'S
CALCULATIONS.
RIGHT NOW HE'S CONTEMPLATING
WHETHER TO TAKE AMERICAN THREATS
SERIOUSLY, BECAUSE WHILE, YOU
KNOW, THIS ADMINISTRATION
STEPPED UP BY CEMENTING UP A
OPPOSITION TO PUTIN AND
CONSIDERING PUTIN'S CORRUPTION
IN GERMANY AND IN OTHER EUROPEAN
COUNTRIES, BUT STILL IN MY MIND
NOT ENOUGH, BECAUSE WE STILL
LIKE A GOOD DOCUMENT THAT WILL
CLEARLY STATE THAT ANY
AGGRESSIVE ACTION AGAINST
UKRAINE WILL TRIGGER NEW
SANCTIONS.
THAT'S A BIG TALK, BUT PUTIN IS
A COWBOY.
WHETHER THE PRICE IS ECONOMIC OR
COMING BACK FROM RUSSIA OR
UKRAINE, WILL BE TOO HIGH FOR
HIM.
>> TALKING ABOUT FOX'S TUCKER
CARLSON AND THE PRO-PUTIN
SENTIMENT I GUESS YOU DESCRIBED
IT AS, SPINNING ON-RARE.
ON-AIR.
LET'S GET NOTICE TASTE OF THAT.
>> EXISTING PRIMARILY TO -- MOST
DANGEROUS ENEMY THEY SCREAM.
CAN'T LET THEM HURT UKRAINE.
TURNS OUT RUSSIAGATE WAS MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN WE REALIZED.
THE STEELE DOSSIER, THE THEME,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA IS BAD.
THE FACT IS UKRAINE IS
STRATEGICALLY IRRELEVANT TO THE
UNITED STATES.
NO RATIONAL PERSON TO KEY DEFEND
A WAR WITH RUSSIA OVER UKRAINEU
>> GARY, YOU KNOW, THOSE WHO
REVERED RONALD AEGON ALWAYS
ABOUT PREVENTING EXPANSION OF
RUSSIA DURING THE COLD WAR AND
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER THERE HAVE
BEEN MOMENTS THROUGHOUT, YOU
KNOW, RECENT RUSSIAN HISTORY
WHERE YOU SEE AMERICANS,
AMERICAN MEDIA FIGURES AND SO ON
SAY THINGS THAT, AND THOSE
THINGS WOULD BE MANIPULATED BY
KREMLIN STATE TELEVISION, BUT
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN SOMEBODY AT
HIGH PROFILE AND POPULAR AS
TUCKER CARLSON, SOMEBODY WHO HAS
THE REACH OF TUCKER CARLSON, TO
SPOUT THIS KIND OF PROPAGANDA?
THESE PRO-PUTIN TALKING POINTS
TO THIS EFFECT?
SEEMS TO ME WE NEVER HAVE SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THAT BEFORE, FROM
THE AMERICAN SIDE?
>> YOU'RE RIGHT.
NEVER SEEN IT, JUST NEVER COULD
HAVE IMAGINED.
THE DAY WOULD COME, AND I WOULD
BE DISCUSSING WITH YOU THIS --
THIS TOPIC.
ACTUALLY, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FOX NEWS FRONT PAGE, THEY ARE
ONLINE VERSION, YOU ALWAYS HAVE
TUCKER CARLSON BUT ALSO MANY
VOICES FROM THE PAST, LIKE YOU
KNOW, NIKKI HALEY, OR FROM THE
PAST, THOSE WHO ARE USING THIS
REAGAN'S LINE AND CRITICIZING
THE SAME ADMINISTRATION THAT
TUCKER CARLSON IS BLAMING FOR
NOT BEING STRONG ON PUTIN.
IT'S EITHER THAT OR
SCHIZOPHRENIA BUT EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS AND, OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW, TUCKER CARLSON HAS BEEN
PROMOTED ON RUSSIAN TELEVISION,
BUT WHAT HE SAYS, UKRAINE IS
IRRELEVANT.
IT'S WRONG.
NOT JUST BECAUSE UKRAINE IS,
IT'S A NATION AND NOT A BUFFER
STATE, THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL
BARGAIN CHIP.
UKRAINE SUFFER FROM RUSSIA'S
VIOLATION OF INTERNATIONAL
TREATY THAT HAD BEEN SIGNED
NUMEROUS TIMES, AND GUARANTEED
TO THE TERRITORY.
IF COLLAPSE OF UKRAINE, AND
THAT'S PUTIN'S GOAL.
COLLAPSE OF UKRAINE'S
SOVEREIGNTY, DESTRUCTION OF THE
WORLD ORDER WE NOW, THAT WE KNOW
SEEMS TO BE --
>> SINCE END OF WORLD WAR II.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
SO THAT'S WHY IT'S NOT UKRAINE.
IF UKRAINE FOLLOWS IT OUT WHAT
ABOUT TAIWAN?
WILL WE BE SO AGGRESSIVE CHINA,
IS AMERICA IN POSITION TO DEFEND
IT?
>> YEAH.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE HIM MOVE ON
TO THAT PA